bonjour faire une calme assis merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france il s'agit donc d'un sommet
créé en 2015 qui a lieu tous les deux
ans quel est l'objectif concrètement de
ce rendez vous bisannuel que la hongrie
marque davantage son empreinte
ultraconservatrice face au progressisme
de l'union européenne c'est une manière
de provoquer bruxelles
bonjour alors là plusieurs questions en
une on déjà je vous laisse le
qualificatif d'ultra conservateurs moi
je ne pense pas que ce soit ultra
conservateur que de vouloir défendre le
modèle familial traditionnel
le but de ce sommet donc et comme vous
disiez qui est axé sur les questions de
démographie
en réalité c'est axé sur certains
aspects la démographie
en particulier les politiques natalistes
voilà parce que déjà le la première
chose c'est de préciser qu' il y a il y
a la volonté de maintenir une croissance
démographique et que pour ce faire le
gouvernement gouache foisy la voie d'une
politique nataliste
par opposition à des politiques
d'immigration choisie à l'ouest du
continent
donc donc ça déjà c'est c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important à souligner
c'est que la question démographique la
question de la de l'évolution
démographique pas juste le nombre mais
aussi la nature de la démographie est
une question centrale est récurrente
dans la politique hongroise maintenant
le évidemment c'est aussi utilisé par le
gouvernement hongrois viktor orban
comme un outil pour faire du réseau pour
faire 2 pour donner une bonne image de
la hongrie dans les milieux
conservateurs partout en europe et
au-delà même aux états unis autour du
premier ministre viktor orban ya donc
marion maréchal qui se dit retiré de la
vie politique française
est-ce qu'elle vient pas
quand même faire de la politique en
hongrie même si elle se dit retiré il ya
aussi
l'ex-vice-président de donald trump mike
pence et puis ce sommet est ce que c'est
une manière de retrouver donc la lumière
pour ceux dont on n'entend plus trop
parler
écouter ça la question la politique je
voulais cela faisait directement à
madame maréchal
pour le reste
oui vous citez mike pence
en effet il est plus sur le devant de la
scène mais je pourrais aussi dire que
c'est un sommet où il y avait quand même
les chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
de presque presque une dizaine de pays
quand même donc non je ne pense pas
qu'on pourrait dire que c'est si
simplement à un sur deux pour remettre
en avant des personnalités
dont on n'entend plus trop parler pour
reprendre votre expression
mike pence soit plutôt que le contre
exemple en fait et comment est-ce qu'il
faut interpréter la venue d'eric zemmour
qui est attendu aujourd'hui à ce qu'il
vient chercher une légitimité politique
sur la scène internationale en vue d'une
candidature présumée à l'élection
présidentielle en france
alors là c'est un commentaire qui
n'engage que moi mais je pense en effet
que comme 2 je crois qu'il est assez
évident que le pire est que nous on va
tôt ou tard annoncé sa candidature ce
voyage et déplacements cette rencontre
avec viktor orban je pense en effet que
c'est quelque chose qui a pour but qui a
un double but le le premier but c'est
évidemment de lui donner une qu'à une
carrure internationale ce qui peut le
lui manquer puisque c'est un personnage
très nationale très axé sur la france
et l'autre c'est aussi de montrer qu' il
y a un
potentiel modèle en tout cas sur
certains aspects et des alliés et que
victor ban qui a une certaine notoriété
dans en france en particulier dans des
milieux de droite
montré qu' il y a un lien il ya un bon
il ya un dialogue entre eric zemmour et
et viktor orban donc c'est comme ça que
je vois cette visite de zemmour en et
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il faut
attendre de ce sommet qui a le plus à
perdre ou à gagner avec ce voyage en
hongrie
au jeu je pense qu'aussi bien les
organisateurs que les que les invités on
considère qu'ils ont
tous à gagner c'est
ce sont des décors dire que ce soit
viktor orban eric zemmour et tout un tas
d'autres participants qu'on a pu citer
clairement cc1 c'est un sommet où il y a
une ligne conservatrice et où il ya des
réseaux qui se fabrique qui se crée qui
s'entretiennent dans dans une europe où
il ya très peu de réseaux conservateurs
en réalité il ya un gros travail de lien
aussi visiblement avec de réseau au delà
de
peut-être de ce coup de com avec avec
donc ce sommet ce qu'ils valent est ce
que quelque chose va ressortir
concrètement de ce sommet où c'est
simplement être sous les feux des
projecteurs
je pense que c'est quand même
essentiellement un sommet qui a pour but
du réseau et de la communication voilà
clairement ses montres envoyer un signal
en particulier dans les pays d'europe
centrale puisque et la plupart des
dirigeants de gouvernement présents à ce
sommet était des dirigeants de où sont
des dirigeants d'europe centrale
donc c'est quand même essentiellement un
élément de communication pour montrer
qu'ils travaillent ensemble 1 et un
message aussi envoyé à l'union
européenne pour dire il y a de plus en
plus de pays qui s'affiche ouvertement
contre les politiques de population via
l'immigration et qui désirent des
politiques natalistes et de protection
de frontières c'est aussi ça le message
et montrer une unité
unité qui d'ailleurs dépasse le cadre de
l'union européenne puisqu'il y avait
aussi le président serbe où le président
de la republika srpska de de mossley par
exemple merci faire un calme assis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef du bureau de poste un journal en
ligne spécialisé dans l'actualité de
l'europe centrale